[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about the
chemistry of consciousness we have
joining us Mike Johnson
Andres Gomez Nielsen hello you two
thank you so much for coming on the show
Mike pleasure to meet you finally in
person it's good to be here thank you
and Andres thank you for coming out for
number two thank you I love it I'm so
happy to meet your co-founder of call
your Research Institute like Johnson
very excited also Mike's an author too
of Principia qualia which is very
exciting you can actually find this on
the web as well that's right my website
open theory on that
on open theory dotnet that links in the
bio and as the co-founders of quality
Research Institute you guys have been
doing this for four years and previously
you guys also both blog at quality
computing and it open theory Donna and
those blog links are below the episode
one with Andres is also below you can
watch us unpack qualia and unpack
consciousness and unpack so much more
valence we're gonna get into all of this
I'm very excited Mike was also
previously doing a hedge-fund work as an
advisor doing a bunch of stuff there 13
years of that or so yeah yeah ish okay
cool
so that's a bit on the intros we're
gonna get right into we have some great
images to unpack with you guys okay we
start off with this big history
perspective on what's happening here on
this playground
earth right and we're kind of passing
the torch from a biological intelligence
to a non-biological intelligence so give
us your take on the synthesis right so
there is it seems like there is this
transition coming where we're sort of
creating this new new thing we were
calling it AI and right now we're in the
driver's seat that may not be the case
forever and ever and there's this
question of what kind of future we want
to live in what kind of future we want
to build or what kind of feature we want
AI to build and so I'm very interested
in the AI question in how to how to pass
the torch in a safe way my my current
opinion here is that we were pretty
confused in terms of what we're actually
trying to do with with AI other than not
have it kill us all or or what not
and and I think consciousness research
and this is kind of an odd statement
here but I think consciousness research
is really the antidote to a lot of
confusion in the AI safety space that
right there is even a powerful statement
all right yeah that consciousness
research is an antidote to a lot of the
confusion in the AI safety and security
research space those words aren't set
that off yeah yes please consume you yes
yes so Nick Bostrom in his book super
intelligence talks about one of the
failure modes of something that could go
wrong and he says that it could be that
we sort of trade-off what makes life
valuable in the pursuit of optimizing
for intelligence optimization for
capacity and his metaphor here is that
we may end up building a Disneyland with
no children
yes this is a very powerful metaphor all
right yeah Disneyland in this case being
a super intelligence that is able to go
and enjoy itself in the cosmos and then
without children being without qualia
without feeling or experiencing the
Disneyland right if there's if there
isn't anyone to enjoy the Disneyland
then what's the point and so this is why
one reason why I'm I'm very passionate
about sort of getting to the bottom of
the mechanics of subjective experience
what has it how it all works
and this is why yeah this is a great
sort of it's it's awesome that you -
here's the Qri logo - which is so cool
it's my first time actually seeing the
logo we didn't have it for the first
episode it's a great logo it's cool that
you guys found each other by you coming
and seeing this as a main issue of
civilization and then Andres was doing
the transhumanist stanford's event there
was an event that you were producing
yeah and you founded or co-founded yeah
I founded the organization yeah and then
Mike came to the event and then you guys
men yeah okay so that's the that's that
origin story of how you guys met and
then also don't get online that you guys
were seeing that someone was saying
something about yeah and the moment I
met Mike at the event it's it's called a
advancing humanities symposium at
Stanford he came up to me and says like
I know what pleasure peace you thought I
was pretty weird at the time but uh I
thought like hey somebody thinking about
this problem is probably you know pretty
valuable I was very skeptical of his
particular solution but I think like hey
like building precise empirically
testable yes hypotheses for like what
pleasure
pain is what conscious value is is
itself like an extremely valuable thing
and like I thought like oh maybe he
might be wrong in the specifics but like
he has the right idea of like producing
these testable predictions yes yes that
what are the both chemical computational
properties of pleasure so that there can
actually be children in Disneyland yeah
right okay and children having fun and
children having fun the you you call it
super happy super intelligent and super
longevity
yes alizarin having fun yes yes yeah
because that is that is what that is
what the god or the experiment or
whatever you want to call it that would
want as the life to evolve to I think as
a as a as a pinnacle okay so yes wrong
wrong why would there be the Disneyland
without the felt experience of pleasure
to the max yeah okay so now we have this
project quality Research Institute so
this is how you guys do the framework of
understanding the new science of
consciousness and then understanding
qualia we'll get to that and actually
how that yeah yeah yeah that's right we
have some images as well as as we go for
this yes one one frame that I like to
put this in is um
alchemy used to be a thing and clearly
something interesting was happening but
everyone was very confused about how to
talk about reality in in this context
and they tried to turn light into gold
and they they were able to do some
things and also wasted a lot of effort
over time and with a lot of effort
chemistry sort of arose from this field
of alchemy and we started to be able to
make very clear sense of what's going on
and frankly what exists as well and what
Qri is doing is we're working to
basically turn consciousness from
alchemy into chemistry
okay so I'm envisioning us over
thousands of years figuring out how to
make into the world to using you know
the periodic table and etc and
discovering the periodic table and all
the different elements etc what are the
corresponding things that we would
expect to sort of discover or explore in
consciousness research what is the
periodic table of the my absolutely
perfect and how to combine the basic
elements in recipes in order to generate
arbitrary states of consciousness in a
precision-engineered way yes yes
okay okay okay all right this is very
good all right okay so we are doing to
the mind what we did with the periodic
table and elements so now we're doing it
to the mind and we're gonna figure out
the catalog of experiences and how to
pursue precisely engineer those
experiences okay and then we're gonna
embed that in the passing of the torch
it's it feels very important that the
the process of passing the torch include
this knowledge yes because otherwise it
doesn't feel like it would lead to
anywhere good yeah okay all right so
to the new science of consciousness yeah
but yeah yep okay all right let's pull
up that first image under new science of
consciousness yeah so these are kind of
a we call it kind of like the eight
problems for a new science of
consciousness it's kind of like a
misleading to think about like the
products of consciousness in terms of
the heart problem relic Chalmers
famously coined that term in terms of
like hey if there's only you know
structure and behavior in a brain like
where does subjectivity come from and if
you frame it that way
it's an insoluble problem because you
start out with the wrong ontology to
begin with on the other hand if you
actually decompose the problem into a
sufficient number of good subproblems
you can get a big picture that you know
if you're able to tackle each of them
independently you will get the solution
an analogy to this is like for example
like in the 18th century people were
thinking about like oh the hard problem
of matter just like that's that's not a
very useful way of thinking about it
right like matter turns out have like
you know four different fundamental
forces and you need to really decompose
it into a lot of subproblems and tackle
them independently so in terms of like
the the problem of consciousness you
have a metaphysics of math and an
interpretation exactly so like
metaphysics roughly speaking is like
what aspects of reality basically
corresponds with consciousness and and
and that will involve things such as
like oh it's consciousness a
computational phenomena there is an
algorithmic phenomena or does it have to
do with the actual physical energy and
that's kind of like to identify what
parts of reality corresponds to
consciousness and that really is a
metaphysics problem but has precise
empirically testable threads that you
can pull to is not just like our mature
philosophy you can actually dive into
and figure it out precisely what it is
then you have like the math which is
like okay you identified let's say like
you that a certain type of feature of
realities is what underlies
consciousness whether it's like
algorithms or physical energy or whatnot
then you have the problem of well what
finds the boundaries of experience if
you have a system what parts of that
system are actually contributing to the
experience that the system is
instantiated that's called the boundary
problem also called the the binding
problem of consciousness and then okay
you define the boundary of a particular
state of consciousness what does it that
state of consciousness feel like and to
actually get an answer to that what you
need is to understand basically what is
like the the state space and the
topology inside that boundary that map's
the states of consciousness so
identifying what part of reality
corresponds to consciousness and how to
create a boundary around it doesn't
fully solve the problem and that's
actually where a lot of theories of
consciousness basically end kind of like
the question of if consciousness is
localized in the mind and then wrap and
then the next kind of step is this
topology of experiences that the mind
can yeah reduce yeah yeah I mean to just
to give you an example I mean it's true
like that would be part of the boundary
problem running in some views you could
be like nonlocalized in buildings
let's say let's take for example of the
work the global work space theory of
consciousness basically says that on any
given moment in time there is a set of
neurons that basically are talking to
each other and is like the largest set
of new you're talking to each other in
the brain the dad maps to your state of
consciousness and maybe there's like
some little islands of new yours that
are you know chattering but as long as
they're not immediately contributing to
the largest bundle interesting that you
you want to be like a conscious of them
now so is this then is this quite
literature solid testing solid that
we've had instances where the when
you're mapping neural activity that
you've seen like a big amount of
activity which you could call the
conscious felt experience in that moment
but in a separate area of a neural
activity happening somewhere else but
that is potentially not part of the yeah
one one sort of a clear example here is
that there are
a lot of neurons in your stomach mm-hmm
but uh you don't feel what's happening
in your stomach except through the
nerves that would you connect your brain
so they're the vagus nerve can be we can
be feeling hunger and that you could say
then is me be conscious experiencing the
neurons attention you you maybe I mean
that's actually pretty tricky and
controversial okay it's a very likely
possibility is that actually the the
phenomenology of hunger is still within
the brain okay
it just being triggered by the neural
impulses from the stomach okay okay and
we know we know that that's repeated
people with like damaged vagus nerves
you can still stimulate some areas of
the brain to make them feel hunger so
it's not like you actually literally
need those neurons there so that
corresponds to like the boundary problem
but then you still have the problem okay
like I'd have to find the boundary okay
like these sets of neurons interacting
in such a way how do I translate the
structure of those neurons interacting
with each other into what state of
consciousness the person is in yeah yeah
like are they experiencing hunger
they're experiencing pleasure are they
experiencing the color blue and so on
and so forth and that corresponds to the
interpretation problem yeah there's a
lot of data that's another one of the
major things is that yeah I think
there's something nuts that yeah and
it's like ninety percent of all of the
data humanity has ever created was
created in the last two years
and then now our biggest problem is
structure it's like 90 percent of all
the data is also unstructured data and
so now when you're trying to this is
this is basically data data data and
then yeah how to actually make sense I'm
this isn't your tackling yeah one of
most important hardest yeah yes it is
this issue of okay consciousness is this
very difficult problem where do you even
start and we think this sort of maps out
where to carve the problems yeah okay
and I mean this is this is why this is
episode two there will need to be more
times of unpacking this but we have so
much still to go on to so let's let's go
let's go on then
okay all right let's go let's go on all
right so now daily about valence yeah so
the the question of where to start you
basically want to find the simplest kind
of qualia you could say this is from Dan
Barkeley the C elegans of qualia
just the simplest model organism so
speak and something that exists in a
real sense it isn't a a leaky
abstraction but it's some part of the
the fundamental features of reality and
we believe that the the way in I guess
one metaphor would be the first line in
the Rosetta Stone of consciousness would
be start with valence start with a pain
and pleasure interesting the first line
in the Rosetta Stone of consciousness
start with valence pain pleasure
no you there's you know you have this
three you've this triangle you know pain
and red pleasure than blue and neutral
and white and then all experience can
fit
all experience would have a valence
associated with it yeah
and so how we're setting this up is um
so if consciousness is is real
then one way to reframe that is it can
be represented by some mathematical
object so what it feels like to be Alan
talans phenomenology could be
represented by a mathematical object and
then some some part of this object some
pattern or property of this math object
would correspond to how pleasant or
unpleasant yes it feels to be okay okay
and know what would this what would this
mathematical association to my felt
state look like anyone just a very clear
example of like a mathematical feature
of an object I think for example how
people used to think that like what is
temperature or is like a temperature
they used to have like these caloric
substance right it's like oh maybe when
you heat up a cup you know this caloric
substance inside it it just spreads out
afterwards then people figure it out
ahead like actually the average speed of
the molecules corresponds to the
temperature so basically that is a
mathematical feature of that object that
gives you these like essentially one
dimensional aspect of it
accepting in valence is really three
dimensions
there's several complications there
because basically on any given point in
time you could look at your experience
in any of the the space defined by this
triangle so most of the time you're not
experienced in pure pain pure pain or
pure pleasure or pure neutral States
most of experiences are mixed you know
and you can imagine I get a super
extreme mixed experience is like okay
let's say you you're enjoying like music
in a concert but also like there's like
something very dissonant in the
background and you're dealing with
emotional pain and you know these very
complicated
state that would be maybe kind of like
up there like in the middle right it's
like a lot of pleasure a lot of pain at
once but let's say like you've you've
been taking antidepressants like SSRIs
for like ten years and you're the type
of people for whom SSRIs have a neutral
hedonic response so basically they
narrow the range of the pleasure and
pain maybe you would be in that extreme
of like Oh things don't feel neither
good nor bad they're just kind of May or
whatever but most most of the time
you're kind of like somewhere in the
middle you're kind of like moving around
in a little bit of a brow
you know Brownian motion over there yes
Institutes of life these ups and downs
even in a single experience in a
location you can be going between
oscillating between your I love being
here with all this to like I have so
much stuff that I need to do or whatever
and so yeah okay now mathematically you
started indicating that this can be like
heating up mmm the way that yeah atoms
are moving in so exactly like if you
identify the mathematical object whose
features are isomorphic to the features
of your experience we basically predict
that like in that object there's some
math you can apply to it that will
output where in the triangle you are
okay
or worried that triangle that object is
which is which is you on a given moment
in time so this really speaks to what
knowledge would look like about qualia
about phenomenology that um if if you
went into went to sleep for a hundred
years then woke up and wanted to figure
out oh I wonder if they've solved
consciousness yet so you uh you went to
the bookstore and just kind of flipped
through qualia 101 or at the download
yeah then
one way to think that it would be
knowledge belt qualia would be sort of
in a table and on one side of the table
would be mathematical properties
mathematical properties of pain
mathematical properties of pleasure
mathematical properties of neutral and
then all the nuance uh well I would say
math on one side and phenomenology on
the other side and then math and
phenomenology makes that pain pleasure
spectrum yeah okay right okay okay yeah
because the phenomenon and the math will
locate you on this yeah okay yeah and so
really reverse engineering pain and
pleasure would be trying to figure out
what mathematical feature they might map
to yes yes okay so now let's talk about
this okay so
and we were indicating this earlier
there's a some neural activity happening
and we're reading it with maybe instead
of the blobby like fMRI resolution maybe
we have some sort of a like a really
powerful signal from an electrode that
we use the etc and we're just reading it
right there let's say the billions of
neurons or whatever the number may be
that we're reading right there now how
would that be math you need to transform
those physical readouts into the
appropriate mathematical object and you
could make a huge mistake there I mean
like if if you think like the
mathematical object is let's say like a
certain type of algebraic ring okay
maybe you're completely wrong and like
whatever transformation you do is not
going to work maybe if it's a manifold
or field okay maybe that's that's where
it's at and right now there are some
interesting candidate mathematical
objects that we're exploring and maybe
we can go into them okay yeah yeah they
said next yeah yeah okay all right yeah
this is the work of a selling at the soy
and and some other people basically
they're taking neural activity
specifically in the form of memorize and
test for diffusion imaging so they
basically map out the shape of your
brain and based on the shape of your
brain you know white matter connections
gray matter connections they apply this
equation the it's called an insight
excitatory inhibitory wavefront that
basically simulates how excitation and
inhibition will propagate in the brain
okay
and just as anything in the physical
world anything with rigidity has like
resonant modes basically ways in which a
wave can travel an integer number of
times and the pattern repeats and
doesn't cancel each other out the brain
also has harmonic resonance and there's
a discrete number of them
so it's like rather than thinking of it
as like oh you know just a lot of
neurons firing in this complex chaotic
indescribable way it's like oh you can
actually describe all all what's
happening in the brain or a big chunk of
what's happening in the brain as a
weighted sum of various harmonic
patterns of harmonic patterns okay
so what's causing it to excite or
inhibit then those neurons and one sort
of simple frame on this is that just
like guitar has natural resonant
patterns yes
frequencies that naturally resonate
within the guitar and a piano would also
have natural resonance
so to the brain would have them and
we're we're suspecting that this will be
an interesting way to proxy
phenomenology and especially the texture
of phenomenology how experiences feel
and maybe I I'm skipping ahead here let
me ask then because I still want us to
want to understand a harmonic is a very
interesting way to think about this yeah
okay so and the connectome is the full
mapping of every thing of everything
specially elect neural contents and
fibers conduits and fighters like the
reason why they're so important is
because the waves travel through them
and then also the reason why you
actually need to differentiate between
the white matter and the gray matter
mm-hmm is because the waves travel
faster in the white matter faster in the
white matter yeah so you could imagine
like we have a table that maybe in like
this the poor and the cortex is great
yes yes yeah okay well slower slower
interesting so like more potentially
primordial infrastructure is traveling
faster maybe yeah sometimes yes I mean
the white matter is associated with like
three processes and things that you need
a lot of kind of like fast reaction time
whereas like the gray matter is like all
four things that was like slower work
okay okay so the the analogy here is
like if you have a table it's made of
iron I just imagine you doing the meme
[Laughter]
is let's say has like a it's is mostly
iron but he has like an aluminum core
the resonant mode of the table like you
hit it with a hammer and you listen the
fact that the center is made of aluminum
will change what notes it can play
because maybe the the waves will travel
faster there so is you need to take into
account basically the speed of the wave
propagation and and doing so in a in a
fairly differentiated way so you can
actually simulate and see Oh what are
the harmonic resonance mode mm-hmm
everything makes sense so far hey by
everything continuous kindergarten of
the universe it's picking up you know
Episode two picks up a little bit more
you know it's like the slope pick up
right okay yeah I know I know we need I
know we need to move on I just love
thinking about it like like a harmonic
because there are also if we can
potentially say you can maybe apply that
Pareto principle that Pareto
distribution to harmonics as well and
say that potentially that only 20% of
harmonic that we can map account for 80%
of the felt experiences yep and then
those 20 are very important yes then go
first for this like the low-hanging
fruit yeah
and that might be things like the in the
extreme pleasure or the extreme yes
pain and where that is and
mathematically getting to that okay yeah
and just to to say a little bit about
why we're focusing on this sort of
analysis of the brain there are a lot of
different ways of looking at the brain
that don't seem to say much about
phenomenology
for example which brain regions are more
or less active it's a it's something
that we look at because we can gather
the data easily enough with fMRI but it
doesn't seem to be useful in in a lot of
ways we can find interesting
correlations but what do they mean
likewise we can measure different energy
and different ueg bands but again what
exactly does that mean
we think that this harmonic analysis of
the brain is especially interesting
because it's not exactly measuring
phenomenology it's not exactly measuring
the texture or context of emotional or
subjective experience but at the same
time it's much closer it's sort of it's
plausible that when when this changes
when your brains resonance changes yes
then what it feels like to give you yes
will also change in interesting ways and
then if we have a subjective if there if
we have humans subjectively explaining
what is happening while they're being
it's an apt to that degree then and then
you have millions and millions of those
examples then you can start saying yeah
but this meant that can build the bigger
build the data okay so now yeah yes okay
yeah so I mean this is kind of like a
toy model okay blah yeah oh yeah I mean
this is remember the Valens girl you're
putting pleasure you're pretty close to
neutral for example okay oh I see okay
that's where the that's there's a dot
there yes yes and that's why it's okay
block man
exactly uh-huh that that's an example
there's other pictures with different
shapes Pierce is ecstatic in the top
right corner yeah so we we may have kind
of buried the lead here in that what Qri
has is we have a method which we we hope
to get some data on soon to basically
put somebody in an fMRI machine and
objectively determine how happy they are
mm-hmm and now before potentially the
next episodes we can write we can talk
about this yeah yeah okay how soon and
how many people will be doing this right
I mean we can go a little bit into the
details of that so yes I mean this is
one not so much as you want there's no
pressure pressure one of the crazy
things is you know like philosophy of
mind right like this thousands of papers
published that we every year but how
many of them are generating precise
empirically testable predictions maybe
half I mean I don't this really rare
actually to have appliquéd ability yeah
replicability yeah yes but what we have
in here is hey from first principles we
are postulating that the feature the
mathematical feature that corresponds to
the valence of the mathematical object
that is your consciousness will be its
degree of symmetry and symmetry here is
defined as invariance up and change so
basically the ways in which your brain
is transforming that object how many of
those are leaving it the same and we
think that that's that's going to be
like the the key for understanding
basically how pleasant or unpleasant
your status
with selling artists always work where
you decompose the brain into its
harmonics it falls out of the math that
basically to quantify the symmetry of
the state you can basically apply a very
similar principle to how to quantify the
harmonic signature of sound basically
you quantify how dissonant it is like a
cymatic yeah yeah like I mean if you
play like 400 Hertz and 450 Hertz
yeah that has to sound rough and
unpleasant and one explanation is that
basically you get like this beat
patterns that within the window of
attention doesn't they don't repeat so
basically they just keep your attention
in its toes so to speak likewise if you
add brain harmonics that are like nearby
like let's say like oh this is a 20
Hertz harmonic this is a 21 you add them
together the whole shape is going to be
discombobulated and we predict that
that's going to be really unpleasant and
okay on the flip side and really
Pleasant States I mean consider like
MDMA for example we predict a good trip
a good trip or MDMA for like this robust
high valence we highly recommend psycho
dog assisted psychotherapy yes Maps yeah
we predict that MDMA states are actually
going to be highly resonant and highly
consonant so like the reason they feel
good is because the harmonics actually
are add up together in a very
synergistic and symmetrical way and
that's completely testable and again
it's not that we have actually looked at
the data and inferred this is more crazy
and daring is saying if our theory is
anywhere in the ballpark of being true
this is what we're expecting to see if
we conduct the experiment and then how
again is
do we get the math of coherence mMmmm
right so I mean this is essentially a
way to quantify the harmony in a brain
so coherence or consonants / harmony all
these are sort of related concepts so
the algorithm and Andres can can also
chime in here but it's basically looking
at each brain harmonic so all of these
in the circle are different residences
in a brain in a single brain and so NAB
and what's the difference between the
small black dots the big black dots the
red area on the left how much energy
there is in each harmonic the black dot
is coming over the amplitude of it it's
the full amplitude of that specific
harmonic so how loud each harmonic yeah
I mean just to clarify like where's
Apple the the very top top was Wonder
you see is like completely blue on one
side completely right on the other lots
of neural activity on the left that is
like actually harmonic number one
harmonic number this is like the lowest
frequency and what's happening there
it's that basically your left hemisphere
is activated while the right hemisphere
is inhibited and then they switch right
so it's kind of like when you when you
make something vibrate yeah
the lowest harmonic is going to be
something that divides the spacing -
they have like oh this side goes up this
side goes down so that that's like the
absolute simplest one lowest frequency
the other ones are like more complicated
like where's Apple the upper left corner
okay you see is like it has like
sprinkles of red and blue there's like
it's kind of like this scintillating
like oh that's a high frequency harmonic
like it's also doing like the
up-and-down thing but it's like lots of
little regions that are like going up
and lots of ridges are going down and
they're alternating so yeah that
basically what that's encoding is like
the frequency of harmonic the circle is
the amplitude and then the arrows is the
degree of interference between those
harmonics so basically if an arrow is
that would mean that hey those two
harmonics are very similar in frequency
okay and that means that they're gonna
cause a lot of dissonance dissonance
it's gonna discombobulated the shape and
people are gonna feel not good yes okay
they're gonna feel more pain yeah
pain discomfort anxiety like okay and
then we're pleasure when it's a blue yes
yes so the graphic on the right is
basically adding up all these pairwise
relationships between these specific
harmonics in order to estimate the total
constants and the total distance and the
total noise and that gives us a location
in valence space okay okay so as in when
when you look what when when I look on
the graphic on the right there's seems
to be more the most state potential in
neutral
mm-hm and then second most in pleasure
yeah and then least most in pain yeah
and you can see that based on the height
of all of those of the gray the blue and
then the red yeah yeah and just just for
completing the picture you also have
kind of like these additional like lines
that would be the spectrum of itch so
one of the kind of like sob predictions
that we're making I mean like the big
big prediction you're like oh adding up
the dissonance will correlate with
unpleasantness adding up the consonants
is correlated with pleasantness kind of
like sob predictions which is more
likely we will get them wrong but we
suspect it goes in that direction
basically low frequency harmonics will
correspond basically with basically
what's called like low arousal in
affective space so let's say you
experience like a low-frequency
dissonance like some of your low
frequency harmonics are in a dissonant
state with each other that's gonna feel
more kind of like depression or like
kind of existential discomfort worse
high frequency dissonance is going to
feel more like inside
this is kind of like this high-energy
feeling of ill-being
whereas if you flip it is like Oh
low-frequency consonants that's going to
feel like relaxation
you know these full-body sense of like
well-being whereas high-frequency
consonants might feel like excitement
like sure okay
interestingly too they should give us a
way to sort of understand or
parameterize the effects of different
drugs for example alcohol caffeine etc
yeah that by their their effect on
pushing energy into the high frequency
harmonics or into the low frequency
harmonics and then also sort of pushing
the system toward consonants or
dissonance or noise within these frames
as well yeah and also it it should
really explain a lot about why different
drugs feel the way they do towards
consonants or towards dissonance yes and
low-frequency consonants or - - receipts
yeah yeah yeah okay thank you Ron
all right okay so can we get to just
quick I want to make sure that on the
math side of things again how does one
start the process of the math again yeah
well so there's like some equations that
tell you basically how to compute the
dissonance between pure tones the
interesting thing is these have been
like being in compute the dissonance so
between tones so take two pure tones 400
Hertz 450 Hertz and this is the
frequency of neuralyzed just in sound
just in sound sound okay okay that has
been pretty well studied for music
theory and and it's been like
empirically determined so basically they
they and this actually goes back all the
way to come host in the 19th century but
because you're playing two frequencies
in music and then you people get to hear
you can you can play with this yourself
if you play the notes and you can say
wow pleasure versus playing the two
notes again
exactly like that yeah yeah yeah so you
play like for example two two notes that
are like one semitone apart that is
really clashing yeah yeah and I mean
like Angela in the literature people
don't know why we think we can explain
why but it's quite quite mysterious
right he's like oh why why is like minor
Keys feel like melancholic or sad and
major key Keys feel like you know
Pleasant and like a bit and what a dog
feel that same thing yeah yes there is
yeah music for dogs yes the dogs feel it
you just need to translate the music
into their vocal range which is higher
vocal range that mean there's a lot of
projection humans is like oh why doesn't
my dog love my favorite band who's like
they for them it sounds like this low
frequency garbage you need to like
translate it into something that's only
their frequency wait do they feel yes
pleasure yes same ones that we feel a
pleasure to in therefore great for dogs
also dogs these like decent and
interesting okay so just to step back a
little bit every every good theory of
consciousness should say should make a
lot of predictions shouldn't make a lot
of interesting novel bold predictions
and so one thing we're focusing on is is
music being able to explain things that
are fairly mysterious otherwise and one
thing we're also focusing on and we may
have time to get to this or not but also
any good theory of consciousness should
let us design better neuroscience
theories and specifically better
treatments for mental health as well
yeah yeah
- the about that that yeah that last one
is you know we were we were talking
about this before him but just the the
speed at which civilization evolved that
we were unable to keep up with the
watering the nutrients of the seeds of
every single mind and so now there is
more of the mental health problems more
of the traumas and so to be able to
solve some of the most pressing mental
health challenges with with this is
extreme saying with this cataloguing in
and there's so many so much good work
being done in the like magnetic
stimulation space in electrical
stimulation space and often we we see
something that works but we don't
exactly know why so our theories would
explain why yes for example kms works
for different yes yes yeah
you know like yeah that's that this is
what yes yes why it works right yes
right if you know how it works it can
improve it you can improve it yeah yeah
and keep yes keep pushing the edge of
knowledge okay so just quick so to go
from sound and seeing what works and
sound to applying that same math to the
consonances and dissonance is that noise
is that that work yeah the brain yeah
yeah I mean like it's a lot of people
who meditate a lot for example like do
report that a lot of like the
unpleasantness of experience come from
like what they might call kind of like a
mental turbulence unresolved patterns
patterns that like don't look good from
every point of view and that we predict
would actually manifest there's like
these big patterns between the various
brain harmonics and one of the things
that meditation does is purifier
harmonics so you're like canceling out
those that interfere with the main ones
we also have like some some work on that
but we probably probably running out of
time
yeah all right one very very important
frame here is uh it's from business that
what you can measure you can manage and
if we have a good sort of picture into
the important stuff going on in the
brain and for example depression or
anxiety or something in that space would
show up in our picture into the brain in
a clear way
then if our proxy is is good enough
basically if we can sort of massage
these brain harmonics back into harmony
we may in fact cure the depression or
anxiety yeah I love the massaging it
back into harmony yeah oh yeah that's
that yes please yeah so for example in
mental health yeah personalized harmonic
re to meek yes yes you got in 2050 and
they do the CDNs analyses and they
figure out in CD a nurse again oh sorry
consonants dissonance noise signature of
your brain one of the things that may
figure out is like hey like it turns out
you know in that diagram over there your
17th and 19th harmonic are in a real bad
you know state of dissonance with each
other how do you fix that it could very
well be that there is like some obscure
substance like for example coal or acid
Tim I tend to bring coal or acetone
because he said pretty understudied and
very interesting it brings really really
obscure and super subtle but it does
something and when something is like
that it may very well be that it's
affecting a very narrow set of harmonics
so it could be that color acid temp for
example inhibits the 17th harmonic and
then like that would mean that you know
most people take it they don't feel
almost anything but if you take it you
feel completely different because it was
the 17th harmonic that was causing so
much problem for you and understanding
the the fine details of what's actually
going on in the brain will open up a
very wide array of interventions yes
much much better than take this SSRIs
yeah yeah yeah the nuke approach versus
a young Asian approach yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay this this is exactly this is
like we're talking just like 30 years
potentially even less hopefully yeah
down the line were this is a a consonant
CD and as a constant distance noise
signature is like a full connectome
analysis that would be no that would be
taking the connectome harmonic analysis
connectome harmonic analysis which is
like the mathematical object yes and
then applying an algorithm okay to
detect the features that matter for
valence okay okay okay
got it got it okay so you're taking the
yeah you're taking another algorithm to
the connectome analysis to then say this
is the CD and ask the valence that the
person's yeah in sync through though the
the analogy again it might be something
like you have like four balls moving
around maybe the kind of like the
mathematical object there is like Oh a
description of like the speed and
direction of each of them but then the
temperature is taking that mathematical
object and computing the average speed
and that gives you the temperature okay
so it's like that layer of this
mathematical object and then there's
like the algorithm to extract the
features that matter okay okay
man now just is just nuts thinking about
how much of this is down at just at the
like kind of like on the chaos theory
butterfly effect side of neurons being
inhibited or excited sure sure because
even just that one or ten or twenty in
that one little area going off and you
know yeah yeah one one frame on that is
there are these attractors in the brain
that sort of attractors right all right
understanding sort of the the state
space of the brain and attractors are
like gravity wells and the brain state
likes to go down in these and and circle
around
and so there are definitely chaotic
dynamics but there are also there's also
some level of predictability yeah and
fixing the brain that's in distance for
example might be a matter of just kind
of pushing it in to out of a batter
tractor and into a better attract yes
yes
and then just letting emergent dynamics
take it from there okay yes yes and that
seems to be what the psychotherapy side
of things really is right now is being
able to take that that what is once
fearful and being able to peacefully be
at peace with it and then not have it
recalled over and over again but just a
peaceful integration of it okay um is
that was that it on the yeah that's it
on the images okay cool yeah okay
all right um now just a you know just a
quick a quick overall along on this
episode
okay so we're talking about the three SS
super happy super intelligence super
longevity of a civilization and they're
needing to be children gonna be somebody
[Laughter]
subjective experience for the children
at play exactly and in sort of the the
futurism transhumanism just sort of far
future frame there are many people
working toward the goal of super
intelligence and there are definitely
less fewer but there are still plenty of
people working toward super longevity
yeah yeah but in terms of working toward
this under even just understanding what
it is but also how to implement it I
think Qri is one of the only
organizations that is working toward
super happiness yeah yeah that this is
this is again we are seeing this across
the geopolitical sphere of the who's
doing the AGI first etc and who's doing
the super longevity first will they
share how will that work you know but
the you know that's interesting on the
super happiness side of things on
understanding the valence is is who's
going super on that right that's you
guys yep yeah and I mean consider
consider a world without that research I
mean in terms of like for example big
countries battling for AGI you know one
of the scary things here is that if you
have any intelligence that basically all
its optimizing is for causal power being
able to modify the world in whatever way
it allows you to make copies of itself
versus another one that is optimizing
also for subjective well-being and
longevity and other values in addition
to making copies of itself the first one
has a huge advantage basically because
it doesn't have to spend any energy on
making the world better that's that's
something we call a pure replicator a
pure replicator yeah it's like taking
the entire power of the star and putting
it just replication there's is also to
well-being because then you'd have to
siphon some of that there's neither also
the world yes and and because they have
an inherent advantage I mean many
evolutionary models would predict that's
what will dominate the future so we
without the children yeah we are in some
sense climbing uphill modulo the fact
that understanding consciousness we
predict will also give us computational
power not accessible to those who don't
understand consciousness that said if we
don't do that fast enough we may be
overtaken by pure replicators wow there
yeah that's the that's another little
race it's not like there's a race this
race of pure replicator versus
replicator with well-being yes we have
valence with experience yeah yeah and so
just to sum up there we think that the
world will be on a very different
trajectory if we figure out AGI first or
before we figure out consciousness
or if we figure out consciousness before
AG yeah yeah yeah
what an interesting wrap on this
conversation so cool what you guys are
doing is so good and also just so cool
the you know this the theory behind it
and the importance of of that very
abstract perspective on an evolution of
a civilization understanding the
consciousness prior to understand are
developing the general intelligence
being paramount that's very very cool um
I love you both a lot I love you both a
lot this is so powerful they give you
[Laughter]
this is great this is and this is this
is um
this is also available is this available
for people to it's for those it's very
exclusive you guys can get one too if
you get on the let's engineer super
happiness train okay cool cool not not
that that's like the ultimate price I
mean but yeah super happiness would be
its own prize I think work with a Qri
and help out and then you can get a cool
cure a yeah yes yes perfect
yes okay seriously keep up the good work
we love you guys so much
I'm quick just uh I want to ask I think
you know we've asked you but I still
want to you know we'll hear Mike's take
on this are we in a simulation I suspect
so so in the last appendix of Principia
qualia I talk about this a little bit
and I think Andres mentioned the general
structure of the argument last time so
okay I don't know if we want to get into
the weeds there but basically two
reasons to be in a simulation one would
be for instrumental reasons or why would
you ever be honest
yeah yeah fur and fur they instrumental
or different for sure
for reading what the experiment is said
yeah if you want to calculate something
in that simulation is the most efficient
way ii will mike johnson pursue the
world right there's so many little tree
of possibilities okay yes yeah yeah
the second reason to simulate something
if you're not trying to calculate
something the second reason is to create
something that is intrinsically valuable
and so if this is the case then we
should see a lot of valuable qualia
scattered around the universe now
there's this problem of suffering where
it doesn't seem like human life is all
butterflies and unicorns and rainbows
all the time at the same time we if we
had a formal theory of consciousness we
can sort of mindfully and formally
explore this for example yes
what if black holes feel like what does
quantum fuzz feeling like what is the
big bang feel like yes and
yeah that's very good if we find out
that the Big Bang is like a supermassive
super intense like yes or yes
that that would be evidence that we're
in a simulation yeah in various testable
falsifiable yeah we need to start
probing the simulation question fact I
want to probe it absolutely yeah okay
the last question is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
oh gosh
I think truth
but it's maybe the only thing you can
build on so I very beautiful whose true
the collective's truth yeah yeah and
this is this is very good okay beautiful
what a what a powerful powerful number -
keep up the good work Qri everyone check
it out the links are below thank you
guys thank you thank you so much thank
you for coming on yes I'm glad you had a
good time
we'll keep we'll keep up the good work
as you do more of the actual someone in
an in an fMRI and then also mapping out
what's actually happening with their
felt experience then we can run that
data through the show explain it to
people what's actually happening
possibly yes that'll be very fun okay
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you tuning in give
us your thoughts in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you about your
thoughts on all this crazy epicness do
let us know your thoughts thank you to
ron vargas for producing and directing
we love you very much
check out cure eyes links below check
out andres and mike's links below go and
check out their work and their blogging
and the first episodes also with andres
below as well and support the artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in in
your communities and around the world
support them help them grow and blossom
their endeavors we need them now more
than ever build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you and we will
see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]